You know, usually when we talk about a medical diagnosis, there's this expectation of precision.
Oh, absolutely.
Like engineering or something.
You break your arm, the x-ray shows that jagged white line, and the doctor just points and
says, there it is.
Right.
It's binary.
Broken or not broken.
I mean, we like things to be visible, right?
To be categorized neatly into little boxes.
It gives us this, well, an illusion of total control.
Yeah, but then you step into the world psychology and suddenly that x-ray machine is just totally
useless.
You aren't looking for a cracked bone.
You're looking for like a cracked identity.
Yeah.
And that is the reality of the Cluster B personality disorders.
Yeah, it really is.
So if you've ever found yourself trying to understand human behavior that just seems
completely chaotic, this is exactly what we are unpacking on today's deep dive.
We are navigating a diagnostic landscape where drama, erratic behavior, and intense emotion
all kind of blur together into one overwhelming picture.
And that blur, you know, that's precisely why this specific cluster of disorders is so
highly scrutinized by clinical professionals.
If you are trying to navigate complex human relationships or you're just someone who's
fascinated by why people do the things they do, this is an incredibly high stakes area
to understand.
Because they overlap so much.
Exactly.
These personality types constantly bleed into one another.
On the surface, the behaviors can look identical.
They really do.
I mean, you look at the surface and it's basically just a storm of intense emotion.
You can easily confuse one of these conditions with another.
Or even, and this happens a lot, confuse them with entirely different psychiatric conditions
outside of this cluster.
All the time, yeah.
So to actually understand these disorders, we can't just look at what a person is
doing.
Yeah.
We have to separate them cleanly by looking at the invisible architecture underneath.
The mechanisms.
Right?
We need to look at their underlying triggers, their hidden motives, and the precise tempo
of their emotional shifts.
Exactly.
We have to look past the symptom and find the mechanism.
And honestly, the best place to start looking for those mechanisms is with Borderline Personality
Disorder.
The big one.
If there is one word that defines the foundational core of Borderline, it is instability.
But not just like the everyday instability we all feel when we're stressed at work,
right?
No, no, no.
This is a pervasive instability that acts like a gravitational pull on literally everything
in the person's life.
We're talking about highly unstable relationships, a fractured self-image, and intensely erratic
emotions.
Right.
All paired with marked impulsivity.
It touches every single aspect of their existence.
People with Borderline, they experience the world essentially without emotional skin.
Wow.
Without emotional skin.
Yeah.
The slightest friction feels like a third degree burn to them.
And this leads to deeply painful internal experiences, like a profound terror of abandonment,
severe identity disturbance, and just a feeling of chronic agonizing emptiness.
Which has to be exhausting.
It is.
Because that pain is so overwhelming, it often manifests in recurrent self-harm or suicidal
behavior as a way to regulate or just escape that immense internal pressure.
Okay.
Let's unpack this idea of emotional regulation because that directly connects to how this
is treated.
The gold standard for Borderline is Dialectical Behavior Therapy, or DBT.
That's right.
But what does that actually mean in practice?
Like it's not just sitting on a couch talking about your childhood, is it?
Not at all.
DBT is highly structured and incredibly practical.
The word Dialectical, it basically means holding two seemingly opposite trues at the
exact same time.
Okay.
For someone with Borderline, the emotional storm capsizes them because they operate
in absolute extremes.
It's all black or white.
Right.
There's no gray area.
Exactly.
So DBT acts like emotional shock absorbers.
It teaches the patient how to say, I am absolutely terrified that you were leaving me and I am
safe in this room right now.
So validating the feeling but grounding the reality.
Yes.
It teaches distress tolerance so they don't have to resort to self-harm when that intense
wave of emptiness hits.
So it's teaching them to like anchor themselves while the storm passes.
Which honestly is a perfect segue into the first major diagnostic trap we see here.
Let's hear it.
When you see someone experiencing massive, intense mood swings, your brain might automatically
jump to a different diagnosis entirely.
Like the biggest trap with Borderline is confusing it with bipolar disorder.
Oh yeah.
It is the most common mistake made by people just observing these behaviors.
But this is where we have to apply that framework we mentioned earlier, you know, tempo
and trigger.
Tempo and trigger.
Yeah.
If you just look at the mood swings, they look exactly the same.
You have to look at the clock and you have to look at the environment.
Okay.
I'm going to challenge you here to map this out for a second.
Is the difference between Borderline and bipolar kind of like the difference between a sudden
violent thunderstorm caused by a specific draft of air versus say a long sustained winter
season?
I love that.
That thunderstorm concept actually maps perfectly onto the clinical reality.
Really?
Yeah.
Let's look at the thunderstorm first, which represents Borderline.
The mood shifts in Borderline are rapid and highly reactive.
They are almost always triggered by an interpersonal event.
Like a fight.
Right.
A perceived slight, a text message left on red, a minor argument with a partner.
That is the sudden draft of air that sparks the storm.
And the tempo of that storm typically lasts for a matter of hours, maybe a day.
Wow.
Okay.
So it's fast and it is a direct immediate reaction to the relationship dynamic in that
very moment.
Precisely.
We contrast that with the winter season, right?
Which represents bipolar disorder.
Bipolar episodes are sustained chemical shifts.
Not just a reaction.
No.
We're talking about mood states, either mania or depression, that last for days, weeks,
or even months at a time.
And crucially, they are episodic.
They aren't necessarily driven by a sudden relationship rupture.
Okay.
That makes sense.
I mean, winter doesn't happen because you had a fight with your friend.
Winter happens because the season change.
Right.
So the key to separating them is looking at the mechanics.
Reactive, fast, and triggered by relationships equals borderline.
Sustained, long-lasting, and episodic equals bipolar.
Exactly.
You are separating reactive emotional instability from a sustained neurochemical episode.
Wow.
Okay.
So if borderline is an emotional storm caused by deep internal panic and a fear of abandonment,
what happens when that same intense emotional energy is used not as a frantic cry for help,
but like as a mechanism for control?
Well, that flicks us into a different category entirely.
Right.
We move away from the rapid reactivity of borderline and into personalities defined by how they
use the people around them.
So let's look at narcissistic personality disorder.
Yeah.
The term narcissist gets thrown around so casually today to describe anyone who takes
too many selfies or acts selfishly.
Oh, for sure.
Everyone's ex is a narcissist now.
Exactly.
But the clinical reality of narcissistic personality disorder is far more complex and specific than
just a vanity.
The core traits are grandiosity, a pervasive need for admiration, and a profound lack of
empathy.
Right.
It's this fundamental sense of entitlement, a belief that they are inherently special,
and a total willingness to exploit others to maintain that status.
But there is a fascinating contradiction here in the source material.
Oh, the paradox.
Yeah.
On the surface, narcissistic personalities project absolute superiority and entitlement.
But underneath that armor, their self-esteem is actually incredibly fragile.
I struggle to reconcile that.
How can someone be so grandiose but possess such a fragile ego at the exact same time?
It is the central paradox of the entire disorder because the grandiosity isn't a reflection
of true grounded self-confidence.
Because true confidence can handle a little criticism.
Exactly.
For the narcissist, the grandiosity is a mask.
It's an elaborate defense mechanism.
They project that entitlement precisely because their underlying self-esteem is deeply vulnerable.
Okay, so it's a shield.
Yes.
If you offer even a mild critique, it doesn't just hurt their feelings.
To them, it threatens to shatter their entire constructed reality.
That's why they often react with such disproportionate rage what clinicians actually call a narcissistic
injury.
So they aren't exploiting people just for the fun of it.
They need the admiration from other people to continuously prop up the mask.
Because the foundation underneath is crumbling.
They require external validation the way the rest of us require oxygen.
That brings us to why treatment is exceptionally difficult.
I bet.
Yeah.
The first line treatment for narcissistic personality disorder is psychotherapy.
But clinical engagement is incredibly hard to achieve.
Well, I would imagine that's directly tied to the empathy deficit.
If the entire goal of psychotherapy is self-reflection and understanding your impact on others, a
narcissist is fundamentally missing the tools to do that work.
Psychotherapy requires vulnerability, you know.
It requires admitting you have flaws and recognizing the pain you've caused other people.
Which they can't do.
Right.
If your primary defense mechanism is projecting absolute perfection and you lack the empathy
to care about the people you've exploited, sitting in a therapist chair and dismantling
your own mask feels like psychological annihilation.
Wow.
So they just don't go to therapy.
They rarely seek treatment unless a major life event like a massive divorce or a huge
career failure forces the mask to slip.
Okay.
So narcissistic personalities exploit people to manage their own fragile self-esteem.
But that introduces another major diagnostic trap, doesn't it?
Because they aren't the only ones who exploit people.
No, they certainly are not.
We have to separate narcissistic personality disorder from antisocial personality disorder.
If you just look at the surface behavior, the fact that someone is being manipulated
or used, you really won't be able to tell the two apart.
Right.
We need to return to our framework of hidden motives.
The surface action is exploitation, but the why is entirely different.
So the narcissist exploits to be admired.
They want the applause to feed the ego.
Why does the antisocial person exploit?
The antisocial person exploits with total cold disregard for whether anyone gets hurt.
And they do not care if you admire them or not.
But no need for applause.
None.
It's not about applause.
It's about a pervasive disregard for the rules of society and the rights of others.
They want power, they want resources, or maybe just simple amusement.
And other human beings are just, well, objects in the way of getting it.
Man, it's a very dark psychological profile.
It is.
We're talking about a core defined by deceit, impulsivity, physical aggression, irresponsibility,
and this chilling lack of remorse.
Oh.
If they hurt you to get what they want, they simply don't lose sleep over it.
And because the implications of this disorder are so severe, I mean, often intersecting with
the criminal justice system, the clinical rules for diagnosing it are incredibly rigid.
You cannot casually label someone with antisocial personality disorder.
Right.
There are specific criteria.
There are two heart and fast rules.
First, the individual must be at least 18 years old.
Okay.
Let me push back on that for a second because that feels arbitrary.
What happens if you have a 16 year old who is clearly showing all these intense traits
that deceit, the aggression, the complete lack of remorse?
Why wait two years to call it what it is?
I get it.
It might seem arbitrary, but it's based on neurodevelopment and ethics.
A teenager's brain, specifically the prefrontal cortex, which handles impulse control and empathy,
is still heavily under construction.
Oh, right.
Because they're still growing.
Exactly.
If a minor is presenting with those exact symptoms, the diagnosis is conduct disorder, not antisocial
personality.
So it's essentially a placeholder diagnosis.
It's more of a warning light, really.
It acknowledges the severe behavior, like violating rules, destroying property or aggression,
but it leaves room for neuroplasticity.
We really don't want to lock a developing child into a lifelong, heavily stigmatized
personality disorder label if there is still a chance that behavioral interventions and
just natural brain maturation can change their trajectory.
That makes total sense.
But once they hit 18, if those behaviors persist, the label changes, which brings up
the second role, right?
You can't just suddenly develop antisocial personality disorder in your mid-20s.
Exactly right.
To diagnose ASPD at 18 or older, there must be documented evidence that conduct disorder
existed before the age of 15.
Ah, so the history is required.
Yes.
Personality disorders are deeply ingrained, lifelong patterns.
If someone suddenly starts acting completely aggressively and deceitfully at age 25,
with no childhood history of it, you aren't looking at antisocial personality disorder.
You are likely looking at substance abuse, a brain tumor, or a severe manic episode.
Wow.
The history has to be there.
And unfortunately, from what I'm reading, the treatment outlook for ASPD is incredibly
grim.
The first line interventions are notably limited and difficult, arguably the hardest
to treat in this entire cluster.
It really comes down to motivation.
Think about borderline, right?
The patient is in immense internal pain, which means they often want relief, even
if the therapy is incredibly hard.
With antisocial personality disorder, there is no internal distress about their behavior.
They don't feel guilty.
Because they don't care.
Right.
The only distress they feel is when they get caught or face consequences.
Without internal remorse or a true desire to change, finding an effective therapeutic
lever is one of the absolute hardest challenges in psychiatry.
Okay, so we've looked at the rapid, painful, emotional storms of borderline.
We've looked at narcissistic personalities exploiting people for admiration to protect
a fragile ego.
And antisocial personalities exploiting people with cold, calculated disregard.
That brings us to the fourth and final disorder in this cluster.
What about the people who aren't necessarily trying to exploit you for power?
And they aren't necessarily hiding a fragile ego, but who just desperately, overwhelmingly
need the world's attention at all times.
That is histrionic personality disorder.
And the driving force here is excessive emotionality and attention seeking.
It's all about the spotlight.
These individuals are highly dramatic, theatrical, seductive, and very suggestible.
But what is really interesting to me is the texture of their emotions.
How do you mean?
Well, unlike the deep, crushing, identity-fracturing pain of borderline, the emotions in histrionic
personality disorder are often described as shifting and shallow.
Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
They can turn on the tears like a faucet just to get a reaction and then turn them
off just as quickly when the audience looks away.
Their primary trigger, the thing that causes them profound, almost intolerable discomfort,
is simply not being the center of attention.
When the spotlight drifts, they will do whatever it takes, whether it's throwing a
tantrum or being inappropriately seductive, just to pull it back.
And like narcissism, the main treatment approach here is psychotherapy, right?
Yeah.
Trying to help them build self-worth that isn't entirely dependent on the immediate
gaze of other people.
That's the goal.
Naturally, histrionic presents another major diagnostic trap.
And this trap brings us full circle right back to where we started today, borderline
personality disorder.
It does, because if you just look at a chaotic, tearful, highly dramatic scene unfolding
in the middle of a restaurant, you might not know which one you're actually looking
at.
Both can feature loud theatrical outbursts.
Right.
I think we could build on an analogy here to help visualize this.
Let's imagine a theater.
Okay.
For me, like the histrionic personality is an actor who just refuses to step out
of the spotlight.
They want the applause, the attention, the sheer drama of the performance.
Yes.
But the borderline personality, they are standing on that exact same stage, making
just as much noise.
But they are doing it because they are absolutely terrified that the stage
itself is collapsing underneath their feet.
I love that.
That collapsing stage analogy actually gets right to the root of the
clinical separator, especially regarding self-harm.
How so?
Well, if the stage is collapsing, you will do anything even hurt yourself, just to
feel some sense of solid ground or to force someone to rescue you.
Ah.
So the motives are entirely different, even if the volume of the noise is
exactly the same.
Exactly.
The histrionic person simply wants to be seen.
What they completely lack, and this is how you cleanly separate them, is the
recurrent self-harm, the severe identity disturbance, the terror of
abandonment, and that profound chronic emptiness that defines borderline.
Histrionic lacks the borderline emptiness.
Borderline is a life or death struggle to hold a fractured self together.
Histrionic is just a desperate bid for an audience.
OK, we have covered a massive amount of psychological ground today, dissecting
the mechanisms behind some of the most chaotic human behaviors.
Let's do a quick conceptual recap to make sure these cleanly separate in
our minds. Let's do it.
Let's run through the core motives.
OK, we started with borderline personality disorder.
The mechanism here is reactive instability and a terror of abandonment,
resulting in hours long mood shifts triggered by relationship conflicts.
And this is managed by DBT, teaching them to weather the emotional storm.
Right.
And we separate it from bipolar by looking for those rapid relationship
triggered shifts rather than sustained chemical episodes.
Perfect.
Then we move to narcissistic personality disorder, where the mechanism is
a fragile self-esteem hiding behind a mask of grandiosity.
They exploit people specifically to extract admiration and prop up that mask.
Which is entirely different from antisocial personality disorder.
Yeah.
Where the motive is pure exploitation with cold disregard for others.
No remorse, no need for applause, just rule breaking and aggression.
And we remember the developmental rule.
You must be 18 to have this diagnosis with a history of conduct
disorder before age 15.
Spot on. And finally, histrionic personality disorder.
The mechanism is an intolerable discomfort with not being seen.
It's theatrical, shallow emotion aimed entirely at securing the spotlight,
completely lacking the chronic emptiness and self-harm of borderline.
We promise to clear up the diagnostic muddy waters.
And by focusing on the why and the how instead of just the what,
I think the invisible structures underneath all that chaos are finally visible.
You really are.
But, you know, analyzing all of this raises a really fascinating,
broader question about the world we live in right now.
Yeah, we spent this entire time talking about how these behaviors are
clinical pathologies, right?
Deeply ingrained disorders.
But look at our modern digital environment.
You mean social media?
Exactly.
It makes you wonder, as our society becomes increasingly driven by algorithms
that reward engagement at all costs, are we actually creating an environment
that actively mimics and encourages these exact cluster B traits
in the general population?
Oh, wow.
Think about it.
Social media practically demands grandiosity
and a curated mask like narcissism.
It financially rewards the theatrical attention-seeking of histrionic behavior.
It thrives on the rapid, reactive emotional outrage of borderline.
And the anonymity of the internet certainly encourages the cold,
rule-breaking disregard of antisocial trolling.
That is wild.
Are we normalizing the pathology just because the algorithm pays for it?
Something to think about.
That is an incredibly provocative thought to leave on.
It completely changes how you view not just the clinical world,
but literally the screen right in front of your face.
Well, maybe next time you're faced with chaotic behavior,
whether it's in your living room or on your feed,
you'll remember to look past the surface drama
and look for the tempo, the trigger, and the hidden motive.
Thank you for joining us on this Deep Dive.
Keep learning, stay curious, and we'll catch you next time.